thank prime minister tirishi
it is an honor and a pleasure to be here
in Windsor with you and it is with a
great sense of satisfaction that we
stand here together
we are about to deliver on an important
commitment we made to each other a few
months ago
I remember our first discussions when we
saw eye to eye on how to support our
Ukrainian friends
and I was encouraged by our trustful and
strong cooperation on this crucial
geostrategic issue
but I also remember how the two of us
were honest with each other
about the difficulties in our bilateral
relationship
and it was vital to put that on the
right footing too
we committed to work hard together to do
so
we knew that for us to be able to make
the most of the potential of our
partnership
Solutions were needed for the issues
around the protocol on Ireland and
Northern Ireland
we knew it was not going to be easy
we knew we needed to listen to each
other's concerns very carefully
above all we had to listen to the
concerns of the people of Northern
Ireland
we knew we had to work hard with clear
minds and determination
but we also both knew their regime that
we could do it
because we were both generally committed
to find a practical solution
for people and for all communities in
Northern Ireland
today we can take pride in the fact that
we have delivered on that commitment
because today we have agreed we have
reached an agreement in principle
on the Windsor framework
The Windsor framework lays down new
Arrangements on island Northern Ireland
this new framework will allow us to
begin a new chapter
it provides for long-lasting solutions
that both of us are confident
will work for all people and businesses
in Northern Ireland
solutions that respond directly to the
concerns they have raised
prime minister we worked hard across a
wide range of areas
the new arrangements are delivering a
comprehensive package
so that we can address in a definitive
way the issues faced in everyday lives
I will only mention two examples that I
find most telling indeed the New Windsor
framework will ensure that the same food
will be available on Supermarket shelves
in Northern Ireland as in the rest of
the UK
and furthermore the New Windsor
framework will permanently enable all
medicines including novel ones
to be available in Northern Ireland at
the same time under the same conditions
across the UK
for this to work we have agreed on
strong safeguards like I.T access labels
and enforcement procedures that will
protect the Integrity of the European
Union's single Market
the New Windsor framework respects and
protects our respective markets
and our respective legitimate interests
and most importantly it protects the
very hard earned peace gains of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement
for the people of Northern Ireland and
across the island of Ireland
violence has no place in our society
I condemn wholeheartedly
the shooting of the psni officer in
Northern Ireland last week
and my thoughts are with the officer and
his family and friends
this year will Mark the 25th anniversary
of the Belfast Good Friday agreement
an important milestone
of the historic peace process
the New Windsor framework is here to
benefit people in Northern Ireland
and support all communities celebrating
peace on the island of Ireland
and this is why I believe we can now
open a new chapter in our partnership
stronger EU UK relationship
standing as close Partners shoulder to
shoulder now and in the future many
things